[Music]
hello world this is random fix and today
I'm going to show you how to program
your ford keyless entry and this happens
to be a 2004 Ford Mustang and this is
really easy you don't need any tools all
you're gonna need is just one key and
however many report remotes you want to
go ahead and put the key in the ignition
and we're gonna be toggling the key a
total of eight times and what you want
to do is pay close attention to the
actual door lock right there I'm gonna
be toggling the key from this position
to that position where the ignition
turns on and back back to the ignition
and I'm gonna do this a total of eight
times I'm gonna show you guys what that
actually looks like so here's what
you're looking for toggle what I just
did one two three four five six seven
eight
right there right when the door locks go
up and down go ahead and hit any button
on the remote
it could be unlock lock and when you're
once you're done whatever everybody
remotes you're using remove the key and
now we can see both of the remotes are
working and this same procedure works
for a lot of other Ford's as well I'll
have a link to these remotes you can get
them for like five six bucks and a lot
of times they'll be ok as far as the
quality the remote the battery numbers
give me pretty poor so you want to throw
a nice Panasonic battery in there so
that way it'll actually last you a
couple of years instead of a few months
but overall I hope you guys liked the
video please leave your comments and
your questions below let me know if you
guys have any comments hit the subscribe
button and I really appreciate your
continued support
[Music]